[Musique]
ange lavenaire bonjour bonjour à tous et
à toutes
et surtout aux joies du marigot lors
d'une bonne année ok vous avez 73 ans
vous avez été maire du marigot de 1995 à
2014 soit pendant 19 ans vous avez été
battu en 2014 par joseph peraste et là
vous vous représentez vous êtes
l'attestent la tête de liste de l'union
pour la promotion et l'animation du
marigot qu'est ce qui vous motive encore
bien plusieurs choses la première c'est
que j'étais battu de 80 voient donc j'ai
considéré que ça n'était pas enrayée
deuxièmement connaissant à celui qui
m'avait battue j'étais persuadé que ça
allait mal se passer
et j'y tenais à rester au conseil
municipal donc j'ai installer le nouveau
conseil le 6 avril 2014 et j'ai procédé
à l'élection du maire puis je suis le
droit y ait du conseil municipal et
ensuite j'ai participé à des concerts
suppôts en tentant de temps son temps de
prodiguer quelques conseils
malheureusement ça n'a pas marché moi
c'est qu'on vous a volé votre victoire
en 2014 parce que au 1er tour vous étiez
en tête de 168 suffrages et au deuxième
tour vous avez perdu vous l'avez rappelé
de 80 voix oui j'estime la craie cité et
j'étais pas le seul d'ailleurs une
injustice une justice une très grande
injustice
nous avions un bon bilan mais le
scandale peut arriver par une tierce
personne c'est arrivé
ce qu'ils nous avaient sauté ben c'est
une une de mes anciens adjoints bon
qu'il avait a fait voter normalement ce
white devrait se représenter dans une
triangulaire
bon je serai réélu
ou bien la limite ne rien dire et
peut-être que le report des voix se
ferait autrement
mais bref c'est du passé maintenant on
va parler de l'est ce que vous avez
digéré avant de parler de l'avenir ce
que vous avez digéré cette défaite
c'était difficile parce que je le répète
j'ai considéré que c'était une injustice
mais après après coup comme déjà prête
c'est une grâce pour toi après 19 ans
passés à la tête de la commune pour quoi
il retournait pourquoi ne pas préparer
une relève pour pas de preuve présentés
quelques que vous pourriez soutenir
c'est vrai mais c'est pas simple par les
temps clicquot proposer à des jeunes ou
quel qu'il soit de s'engager
c'est compliqué alors ils préfèrent et
puis je crois que c'est une
reconnaissance au mois n'est ce pas de
bon capitaine l'équipe
donc ils m'ont demandé de revenir mais
je dois dire que c'est la gestion
aujourd'hui qui me pose problème et qui
fait que je suis très motivé pour y
aller avec mes amis parce qu'on est
aujourd'hui nous sommes il faut arrêter
le massacre marigot c'est quoi le
massacre ben parce que rien ne marche
rien ne se fait et puis qu'on attend du
baroque du bavardage à la télé de
l'agitation et n'est ce pas la
gesticulation
ça n'est pas normal aujourd'hui j'ai été
battu sur tirreno football on va
reconstruire dans les six mois
ça résonne encore en tête des marigots t
on n'a rien vu les sharks ont dit ça va
commencer tiens ça devrait commencer en
janvier le terrain de football
alors qu'au conseil municipal on n'a pas
débattu n'y a pas de projet il n'y a pas
de plan de financement mais on annonce
des choses pour faire bien aujourd'hui
moi quand je vois c'est un budget n'est
ce pas comme fctva un peu plus de 80000
euros la caisse chez le fonds de fonds 2
des sultans la terre se tva fctva
donc c'est quand il ya des
investissements donc l oms retour sur la
tva qui rembourse à la vie quels sont
vos programmes quelques kehl quel est
votre programme tv en ligne de votre le
corps et j'ai dit à mes amis on ne va
pas aller proposer des monts et
merveilles aux gens c'est faux
aujourd'hui les gens savent que la
situation financière partout et
difficile objectif immédiat des prix il
a des priorités qu'il ya première chose
à faire c'est d'abord faire le point
n'est ce pas l'état des lieux
financièrement et sur les bâtiments
communaux
parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait pas en
années ni financièrement
quand je pense qu'au mois de décembre la
mi décembre la commune le maire fait
voter au conseil municipal une décision
modificative pour trouver trois cent
mille euros dans tous les fronts tu as
pop et le personnel en disant il ya un
problème
donc nous on s'est déroulé à ça quand
aujourd'hui nous voyons que tous les
comptes communaux sont fermées des
autres munitions ne donne plus rien il
ya un problème il faut qu'on en parle
donc il faut qu'on fasse le point sur
tout ça on se lave nerfs léger remercie
déjà mais oui ça fait déjà cinq minutes
exactement à ce mythe
oui c'est vrai j'adhère je vous remercie
d'être merci beaucoup
et bon courage à tous les mâles gauthey
[Musique]